où
[Musique]
les français se souviendront de trois
lettres
vge qui
souvent été utilisée pour le désigner et
qui resteront dans les esprits les
français et puis se souviendront d'une
phrase qui que tout le monde connaît
aujourd'hui encore vous n'avez pas le
monopole du coeur avec une phrase dans
un débat en 1974 le candidat à la
présidentielle valéry giscard d'estaing
a montré ce qu'ils avaient non seulement
un grand esprit de répartie mais qu'ils
étaient capables de deux d'emballer un
débat présidentiel de deuxième tour lui
qui était un candidat qui venait qui
était un candidat surprise est donc
cette phrase elle dit beaucoup de son
brio de sa décontraction de son sens de
l'à-propos hills et je pense que c'est
une phrase qui restera qui sera toujours
attaché au fond à à ce troisième
président de la république française il
ya une autre phrase un peu moins connus
mais qui dit aussi le côté moins heureux
de
valéry giscard d'estaing c'est celle
qu'il a prononcé lors de l'allocution de
départ après sa défaite
en 1980 il avait dit au revoir
il s'était levé et il avait laissé le
cadre vide
tout le monde avait considéré que
c'était une manière de partir très
maladroite qui montrait son dépit son
refus de la défaite et qui faisaient qui
donnait à son septennat une coloration
ajustements crépusculaire donc je pense
que on se souviendra de ces deux phrases
et en tout cas de la première qui plus
solaire qui est plus heureuse et qui qui
est le grand moment de l'accession au
pouvoir de ce tout jeune président je
pense que c'est vrai que valéry giscard
d'estaing est coincé entre la grande
dynastie bolobo liste avec le général de
gaulle puis ensuite son successeur le
plus proche pompidou et puis ensuite
l'alternance socialiste et donc il était
il est pris entre ces deux époques qui
ont duré longtemps et lui il a son
septennat hecquet longtemps été
considéré comme un septennat volés par
les gaullistes et je pense qu'on
retiendra qu'il qui l'aura été par
excellence le président des années 70 le
président de la toute jeune télévision
couleur le tout le président des films
de l'époque des films de claude sautet
un président qui avait quand même le
goût de la vie qui qui voulait s'ouvrir
sur la nouvelle société qui voulait
tenir compte de des événements de 68 et
du changement
les grandes révolutions de moeurs qui
est 2 et 2 et des grandes révolutions
sociales qui était en train de
transformer le pays
je pense que se souviendra de ce
président qui voulait incarner une
manière de présider plus décontractée
[Musique]